TO COMMIT THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY
UP NEXT FROM NEW YORK.
>> Sean: THANK YOU AND
WELCOME, DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE OF
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE SENATE, THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES FOR
OVER A MONTH.
AND PRETTY MUCH UNMITIGATED
DISASTER SETTING BACK THE
COUNTRY IN NUMEROUS WAYS TO SAY
THE LEAST.
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WAS
A WEEKLONG ALL-CONSUMING
POLITICAL STUNT.
THE IMPEACHMENT CHARADE WITH
BREED DETERMINED OUTCOME AND
NOTHING AT ALL ACCOMPLISH ENDING
WITH ACQUITTAL.
THE SECOND ORDER OF BUSINESS WAS
LEGISLATION THAT IF PASSED WOULD
BAN PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS FOREVER.
IN EVEN ARLINGTON NATIONAL
CEMETERY AFTER HE DIES.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC
WHERE OVER 100,000 AMERICANS
DIED DURING JOE BIDEN’S TIME IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, RAGING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS STILL THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE MEDIA
MOB’S TOP PRIORITY.
THEY ALSO JUST INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD FURTHER
UNDERMINE ELECTION INTEGRITY AND
ALSO PROVIDE CONGRESSIONAL
VOTING RIGHTS TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
CLEARLY THE SAME DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN IN NO PARTICULAR RUSH TO
PASS COVERT RELIEF PACKAGE AND
GET MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF
AMERICANS WHO ACTUALLY NEED IT.
NOW, THEY ARE FINALLY GETTING
AROUND TO THAT WITH A MASSIVE
1.9, NOT MILLION, NOT BRILLIANT
BUT TRILLION DOLLARS SPENDING
BILL AND UNFORTUNATELY IT’S A
LITTLE MORE THAN A WISH LIST FOR
THE RADICAL LEFT, MASQUERADING
AS A COVID RELIEF PACKAGE.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" RIGHTFULLY
CALLING AT THE NONCOVID SPINNING
BLOWOUT ASIDE FROM DIRECT $1400
PAYMENTS TO AMERICANS, MANY OF
WHOM NEEDED TO.
THE BULK OF SPENDING IS
UNRELATED TO GETTING MEDIA
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE TO NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN.
IN FACT NEARLY $700 BILLION TO
BE UNTIL AFTER 2022 AND BILLIONS
NOT SPENT UNTIL AFTER 2024.
SO WE MUST ASK OURSELVES
TONIGHT, HOW IS THAT COVID
RELIEF?
A WHOPPING $350 BILLION
EARMARKED AS A BAILOUT FOR STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, WHICH TO
TRANSLATE FOR YOU MEANS THAT RED
STATES THAT ELECT FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE GOVERNORS AND
LEGISLATURES THAT BALANCE THEIR
BUDGETS COME UP ON THEIR
PENSIONS, THAT HAVE LOAD TAXES,
HARD-EARNED DOLLARS FROM PEOPLE
IN THEIR STATE WILL BE THEN BE
TRANSFERRED TO BLUE STATES THAT
HAVE MISMANAGED THEIR BUDGETS,
NEVER BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS.
TEXT THEIR RESIDENCE INTO
OBLIVION AND NEVER FUND THEIR
PENSIONS.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO PUT IT
NICELY, WELCOME TO THE BIDEN
UNITED UTOPIA OF AMERICA.
IN OTHER WORDS, MANY FROM
PHYSICALLY RESPONSIBLE STATES.
YOU VOTE FOR POLITICIANS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
THAT MONEY LIKELY WILL GO TO
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA, WHICH ARE GROSSLY
MISMANAGED, ROCKED WITH
POLITICAL CORRUPTION, AND THE
SPINNING PACKAGE ALSO SETS ASIDE
$50 MILLION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GRANTS.
$112 MILLION FOR A TRANSIT
PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW, WHERE NANCY PELOSI
LIVES.
$1.5 BILLION FOR THE SEAWAY
INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE, WHICH
CONNECTS CANADA TO NEW YORK.
OH, CHUCK SCHUMER’S HOME STATE.
$10 MILLION FOR A
NATIVE AMERICAN LANGUAGE
PRESERVATION PROGRAM,
$500 MILLION FOR MUSEUMS AND
LIBRARIES.
HERE WE GO AGAIN, THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES, THEY WILL GET A TON
MORE MONEY.
$40 BILLION FOR COLLEGES,
UNIVERSITIES, WHICH HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING TUITION THE ENTIRE
TIME.
$750 MILLION FOR "GLOBAL
HEALTH."
GLOBAL HEALTH, IN OTHER WORDS
HEALTH CARE FOR PEOPLE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THAT IS THE AMERICA LAST AGAIN.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, $1 BILLION
FOR "SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS."
AND ACCORDING TO A FOX NEWS
REPORT, THAT WHEN INCLUDE AN
EQUITY COMMISSION, AND OTHER
SYSTEM TO ADVANCE RACIAL
INJUSTICE IN FARMING.
AND GET THIS ACCORDING TO THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS, THE BILL WILL INCLUDE A
$15 FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE
MANDATE.
THE CBO IS REPORTING THAT THIS
WOULD RESULT IN THE ELIMINATION
OF 1.4 MILLION JOBS AT A TIME
WHEN MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
OUT OF WORK.
MORE EVERY DAY IS JOE BIDEN WITH
THE STROKE OF A PEN IS LITERALLY
ELIMINATING HIGH PAYING CAREER
JOBS IN THE ENERGY SECTOR.
NOW, OF COURSE, NO DEMOCRATS
WINNING THOSE COMPLETE WITHOUT
SUBSIDIES FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, FEDERAL MONEY FOR
ABORTIONS, IF PASSED, DON’T
WORRY PLANNED PARENTHOOD WILL
NOW QUALIFY FOR PPP SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS, WHICH THEN
BECOME GRANTS AND BRIDGES TO
CANADA COME ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE EQUITY COMMISSIONS,
FARMERS HEALTH CARE AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
NOW ALSO A BUDGET BAILOUT REALLY
FROM NEW YORK, FOR ANDREW CUOMO,
GAVIN NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT A SERIOUS THOUGHTFUL
COVID RELIEF PACKAGE.
WHAT THIS REALLY IS IS A MASSIVE
FEDERAL PAYOUT TO EVERYONE AND
EVERY STATE WHO DONATED TO AND